2021 was a pretty good year for apple
with a lot of awesome product releases
like the new 14 and 16 inch macbook pros
but there were actually a few stones
that apple left unturned as we broke in
the new year and thankfully we're
starting to get some major clues as to
when apple's next event is gonna happen
and what exactly we should be expecting
so what i'm gonna do in this video is
break down the new major apple products
that i fully believe are gonna be coming
at that event as well as the important
details you need to know about those new
products but before we begin let me give
you guys my thoughts on when this event
will take place as we all know apple
hosted their spring event last year in
the month of april but that's only
because the original march date ended up
getting delayed and if you look at
apple's past spring events they almost
always took place in march so april was
an anomaly so in my personal opinion i
believe apple will be holding a march
event this year especially since some of
the products that were supposed to get
released last year in october were
delayed and i think they've been sitting
around just ready to go waiting for the
next event so i think it makes sense for
that event to happen sooner than later
hence the march event now with that said
getting into the products that are
likely to be revealed the first one
we've got to talk about is the mac mini
yes this mac mini has been rumored for
months now and john prosser originally
showed off the leaked design many many
months ago and as you guys can see it's
definitely much thinner it's got a lot
more ports and it has a plexiglass top
for better wireless connectivity now it
was originally supposed to come out last
year alongside the macbook pros at least
according to myself and dylan dkt but
that did not happen because apple
decided to give the macbook pros all of
the spotlight so they had to hold off on
the mac mini and i fully believe that
it's actually been ready for a while
just sitting there waiting for an event
because the redesign justifies an event
reveal and not a regular press release i
also fully believe that it's going to
come packing m1 pro and m1 max chip
options but probably not the new crazy
m1 max duo that a lot of us have been
recently speculating about and we know
this new mac mini is coming for sure
because apple is still selling the
high-end intel mac mini model so this
one is gonna directly replace it and
it's gonna sit above the m1 mac mini and
in terms of the pricing i think it's
going to come at around
12.99 which is actually a good deal
since you're getting the m1 pro chip
compared to paying 2 000
for the 14 inch macbook pro and in terms
of the new second generation m2 mac chip
i don't believe that a mac mini with
that chip is going to be coming until
later this year because i think it's a
low end chip that's going to replace the
m1 mac mini now moving on to the next
product we have the high-end imac now we
obviously know this one is coming
because apple is also still selling the
27-inch intel model on their website and
apple needs to replace it in order to
finish out their two-year apple silicon
transition so i fully guarantee that
this new high-end imac is coming at
apple spring event no doubt about it now
last year dylan dkt was actually the
first one to say that it was getting
delayed until the beginning or the first
half of 2022
and then ross young chimed in and he
more specifically said that it's coming
in the first quarter of 2022 which is
the end of march this is one of the
reasons why i fully believe we're
getting a march event instead of an
april event if ross young's rumor is to
be true now in terms of the design i
expect it to look almost exactly like
the current 24 inch imac just basically
bigger i think it's going to have the
same size chin but the body is going to
be proportionately thicker to allow for
better cooling and more ports and just
to look proportional or good however
this new model is likely to come in a
new space gray color possibly silver but
i'm not sure it all depends on if apple
is going to be calling it the regular
imac
or the imac pro now in terms of the
display size we're almost sure it's
going to be a 27 inch display just like
we had before according to ross young
who has not been wrong yet but he does
believe it's coming with 120 hertz
promotion and mini led technology and
that's going to be likely on at least
one of the models now as far as the chip
and the performance the m1 pro and m1
max chip options are guaranteed but
dylan dkt recently said he believes
there's a good chance that it's gonna
come with at least one more powerful
chip option which i believe is gonna be
the m1 max duo so it's essentially going
to be two m1 max dies connected together
bottom to bottom using special fabric
and i believe this is because the m1 max
die has a totally secret die to die
interconnect section on the bottom which
apple chose to completely edit out of
their dye images and then in terms of
the pricing i fully expect this to start
at around two thousand dollars with the
regular m1 pro chip and it's gonna get
vastly more expensive as you go up to
better chip options now moving on to the
next product that we should expect we
have the new ipad air 5. and this one is
an obvious move by apple because the
current ipad air 4 is grossly outdated
compared to the even cheaper ipad mini 6
since the current air still has the a14
chip compared to the a15 and the mini so
it makes no sense at all in the lineup
and because of that i can 100 guarantee
that it's going to be coming this spring
but i'm not exactly sure if it's going
to show up at the event or if it's just
going to be a press release now just the
other day apple actually registered
multiple model numbers with the eec
which means that we should expect this
new ipad to come soon for sure but in
terms of the upgrade i believe it's
going to be very boring i think it's
going to have the same price as before
but it's just gonna get updated to match
some of the specs of the ipad mini 6 but
with some extra upgrades we should be
expecting the new 12 megapixel ultra
wide selfie camera with center stage
support we should expect the a15 chip
optional 5g cellular connectivity quad
led true tone flash and maybe even quad
stereo speakers and an ipad pro like
dual camera system on the back and now
with that said we finally have the new
iphone se3 which has been rumored for
many months now and unfortunately this
is also going to be a very minor upgrade
instead of the awesome 6.1 inch display
that was rumored in the past it's not
going to be getting a redesign at all
and it's going to be sticking with the
same 4.7 inch display design as before
which does include the home button and
as far as the new features it's simply
going to get a spec update with a new
chip most likely the a15 chip 5g
cellular connectivity and that's
probably it and in my opinion i think
the price is going to stay at the exact
same 399
which is going to make it a big deal for
emerging markets like india now as far
as this new iphone i think there's a
pretty good chance that it's actually
going to be released with a press
release instead of being shown off at
the spring event because it is such a
boring update and we did get some leaks
from leaks apple pro which showed that
apple may have delayed it until april so
it'll be perfect for a press release but
other than that there's a chance we'll
be getting some other new products maybe
like a new iphone 13 color or maybe just
some updates to some of apple's less
popular accessories or products but we
don't really know because we don't have
any rumors in terms of those products
but there you guys go if you're excited
for apple's upcoming event then go ahead
and click the circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one check out
one of those two right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]
you